d4 d5 c46 okay let's do it
okay so now we played what his username
wants us to play
now we can sync n3 okay let's go
i don't know let's go h6
h6 is obviously a stupid move but it's
not that stupid that
that one might sink i think i faced it
many times playing blitz against the
dimmer for the safe and i actually
realized it kind of makes sense
so now we go knight f6 so the point is
basically there is no bishop g5 anymore
then after bishop f4 we go bishop d6
and we are sort of okay with what we get
yeah and go with this mg3
logic okay
e3 probably yeah
now the move i sort of want to play is b
super 5 but then he
probably has queen b3
queen b3 96
yeah i don't know let's do it anyway
that was bishop district yeah this is
more solid but then black should be
completely fine i guess now i can just
play c6 to create and play
sort of wow he castle spawn this is
impressive
okay let's go locate anyway another
thing
yeah now it would be nice to check my
team because otherwise
otherwise i couldn't be checkmated
myself okay let's go a5
so yeah the plan is to push the pawn so
he will do something
then we'll think
you should probably do the same though
maybe just have four now then bishop h4
f4 looks kind of reasonable although in
general i'm not a big fan of
of his concept to be honest
okay
yeah goes f4 okay let's try knight
before and then if he plays
i'm queen e2 or congito i want to play
quincy 25 check
yeah i don't know if it really makes
sense though
i mean it looks reasonable to play queen
five check but then in terms of ideas it
will run into some g4 at some point
i'll do it anyway
so he should probably go to c1
as after king a1 yeah he goes to c1
is there something smart here
yeah i mean if a lady if i open it slow
he will just play g4 and uh
yeah i can play 94 but then g4 still
exists
yeah i could also take only yeah that's
i don't know let's take one
it's actually a bit too messy for a
blizz game but okay
so he could play three now then i'll
probably take on his three it takes b4
take on d1 and take him before and i'm
fine
and knight x3 is a strat anyway
maybe something like rook d2 makes sense
now yeah well
actually very strong player it seems
yeah now i can play some random move and
then after h3 just fine
or
there is no or in fact
yeah okay let's just do it then cringey
six h3 take on the phone
yeah again it's not that i'm a big fan
of what we're doing here but at least it
kind of makes sense it shouldn't be
hopeless probably worse but it's not
not that low sometimes
yeah and that's why we should normally
play this increment i guess because he
will just end up being
being clocked or borrowing something
from your friends
those bishops okay now i can take you to
now i can like yes take on history
yeah and he lost some time well he
played sort of okay
uh before this time trouble started